[Musica]
quando leggo io tutti quanti sulle mani
mentre tutti ascoltano soltanto i sette
nani queste così pali da ma più problemi
a vai a farti una lampada o metti un po
di far non è che si stupiva e che sei
bionda a te manco lo specchio delle mie
brame ti ascolta io sono troppo stilosa
e tu mi co.pe i tuoi fashion stylist
sono dei top io baciato il principe la
sera della stessa tu al massimo è basato
sulle mani sulla testa
sì così bianche che manco ti vedo
vestita così sembra un attaccante del
chievo non capisci niente se parliamo di
calcio se io sembro del chievo tu sembri
della lazio se uno strazio e al massimo
poi a fine partita pulire li sbagliato e
non ci troppi mele e renditi conto il
nome bene può farti da sponsor ma sei
l'unico caso al mondo per cui non vale
una mela al giorno toglie il medico di
torno è andata da foot locker per
comprare la scarpetta ed hanno venduto
solamente la soletta rappa nonché meglio
anastasia genoveffa tornatene a casa che
mezzanotte e mezza devo tornare a casa e
chi mezzanotte e mezza ma almeno una
casa ce lotus sta in una foresta di 6
addormentata ma la cosa bella che ti ha
baciato il principe avevi la tia bella
il tuo principe azzurro invece non torna
più ti ha lasciata per una cubista
brividi bodibi bu e non tipo appeno
disco perché a 12 anni tornava a casa
più tardi di te
[Musica]